expect increased security at schools
this morning vague threats of violence
against campuses nationwide are
spreading now on social media in fact up
in carson city the school district there
even closed all schools today in clark
county classes are still going on as
planned dr mehia joins us live and
hector ccsd is taking this very
seriously
yeah and some students were told not to
bring a backpack to class today we
should point out though that the threats
do not name a specific school this is a
trend happening nationwide it's been
called a trend and here at rancho high
school we are seeing the first round of
students arriving outside staff members
also arriving it's the last day of
finals week here as it is across the
clark county school district and leaders
here locally reiterate the social media
threats and rumors are vague today is
the last day of classes before winter
break the anonymous post training on
tick tock warned that multiple schools
nationwide would receive shooting and
bomb threats in response late last night
the carson city school district decided
to play it safe and keep all campuses
close today just about 15 minutes ago i
checked their website the superintendent
richard stokes pointed out the threats
have not been deemed credible by any law
enforcement agency and appear to have
originated outside of nevada but they
are working closely with the carson city
sheriff's office and so is the clark
county school district working with law
enforcement agents here locally and they
tell everyone reminding everyone if they
see any threats online to go ahead and
report them directly to law enforcement
instead of spreading them on social
media we'll let you know what we see
here in the next 30 minutes or so
reporting live hector mejia live local
now